what's up flagrant crew
it's your boy jiggity dende
I was just wondering if and when you
guys have kids
would you rather they be conservative or
liberal while they're growing up
and would it depend on their gender as
well
good question thanks guys
that's a really good question
facts conservative daughter for sure
probably conservative son too bro at
least
think about that that's a great question
what do you want your kids to be how
strong should we talk you want a liberal
select daughter just running around oh
[ __ ] sexually empowered everything
that's the most liberal on everything
but that's really interesting like if
most people want their kids to be
conservative right yeah then you want
the world to be conservative you want
other people to be liberal
but what do you want your kids to be
yeah now I want my kids I'm sure we all
want our kids to be open-minded yes
absolutely I want them to be liberal in
that regard yes you know but in terms of
uh
so you're unliberal well I want them
liberal yeah but in terms of my daughter
I don't want her to be too liberal what
if she's conservative then goes to
college and yeah that leash was too
tight and now it's even tight never
loses loses it only loosens I mean you
knew those things no no can I tell you
it's only with religion that it loosens
conservatives that aren't that religious
that go to school don't go oh Karl Marx
is my savior
I'm not talking about them getting into
Marxism yeah what are you talking about
he's worried about them getting into it
oh just getting smoked yeah they're
gonna get smoked no matter what
of course 100 I'm talking about like
politically oh like the conservative
chicks that you went to school with
they're still conservative now yeah yeah
you know what I mean like that now the
religious chicks you might have gone to
school with sometimes they lose that
[ __ ]
yeah they flip because they feel like
the whole world was like why aren't you
yeah which is I think something religion
needs to address it's like it's like uh
religion is like mainstream media it's
like wait you presented this thing as if
there's no other alternative whatsoever
didn't tell me and then I got out there
and I saw what's out there and I resent
you for quote unquote lying to me or
whatever it might be better if it's at
least acknowledging the other things
that are out there acknowledging at
least talking about things you're going
to see and then when they experience
them they're like they at least have
some preparation when someone goes yeah
you can [ __ ] whoever you want doesn't
matter then you can be like yeah you can
you can but that might not make you like
emotionally happy right and if that
thing doesn't make you emotionally happy
then maybe it's not something that I
want to do yeah instead of just like
they've been restricted my whole life
what should I do which I think is what a
lot of kids feel yeah yeah
yeah so fix that God but
yeah [ __ ] great question what would
you guys you didn't answer
I don't know I guess it depends what you
count as like conservative or not like
your family
sexually or like what are you like
socially like yeah I want my kids to be
like socially open-minded yeah socially
liberal sexually conservative
ethically
but they don't have any conservatives
money anyways which is the most annoying
everybody who has no money should be
conservative yeah that's what I'm saying
because you're being conserved yeah I'm
conserving you but if you have no money
I don't want to conserve there I have no
money I want to be progressed into more
money yeah yeah
I want to be progressed into Universal
biggest income give me money now oh wait
a minute maybe everybody should be
liberal if they're because they're just
receiving payouts every child should be
liberal because that's what life you
live you live off of somebody someone
takes care of you yeah saying if you're
20 and you're a conservative you don't
have a heart yeah it's 30 and you're
liberal you don't have a brain yeah that
part is what but the younger part makes
sense of course college kids are always
so liberal because you got a bunch of
loans you don't even realize you to pay
back yo there's a there's a
a buddy of mine he manages money and uh
for like some [ __ ] you know
billionaires or [ __ ] like that and uh
some of them are like the kids of oil
people and sometimes the kids of the old
people go I don't want to invest any of
my money in fossil fuels and it's like
do you realize where this money came
from well that's the van Gogh people
like the that non-profit that does like
the climate activism that throws the
tomato soup or whatever yeah like that
is attached I think I read like one
[ __ ] article but it's like attached
to a specific non-profit that non-profit
was created by the daughter of an oil
tycoon who had a house like in Malibu
whose property value was being
threatened by like rising sea levels so
the whole thing is to protect the
[ __ ] house well that's what people
are saying but like that's when she said
she was inspired is when she realized
like it affected her on an individual
level blah blah blah I mean I just I
couldn't believe it which is usually how
people are affected though yeah of
course you only care when it affects you
yeah yeah
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
I got to make sure you don't tear up
your lungs and you're gonna do that with
the freeze pipe okay the best Bongs in
the [ __ ] business look at this
not only are they beautiful impressive
okay you ask a chick to come over you
pull out one of these she don't know
what to do she don't know what to do you
ask a dude to come over maybe you're
trying to hook up with a dude ladies or
fellas you know what I mean you bust out
one of these he might sit on it that's
how comfy these are and he doesn't even
know about the glycerin chambers that
make it extra cool why do you think they
call it the freeze pipe that smoke is
extra cool coming into your throat and
lungs okay fast forward
is sliding down your throat into your
lungs fast forward with the freeze pipe
because the freeze pipe has got your
back them glycerin Chambers
I'm telling you never had smoke this
cold okay you're not going to be
coughing throat on fire you're gonna be
taking the biggest bong grips you've
ever taken your life thank God to the
freeze pipe they got it and they got
your back okay so for the smoothest
glass pieces at every day great prices
go to thefreeze pipe.com use the code
flagrant you're gonna get 15 off your
order that's the freezepipe.com use the
code flagrant for 15 off shop today your
throat and your lungs well thank you now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
clip you could join the [ __ ] Army and
you should at patreon.com but yeah I
don't know I'm like I want my kid to be
probably I mean I think my kid will
probably just be like liberal until
they're like having kids and 45 and then
they'll be conservative then just like
kind of most people I think once you
have kids that [ __ ] starts tightening up
bro I didn't even see it from my friends
you have kids and money and all of a
sudden it's like yeah let's just kind of
keep it that's what conservative is like
yeah it's a I was talking to uh
yeah I was talking to Rogan about this
and I was just like yeah I don't know
like weird things happens like when you
have a little bit of money and you don't
have children it's like it's hard to get
involved in all like the political
melodrama because it just seems like
[ __ ] it's the same people crying
about you every single day and he goes
wait till you have kids I go what do you
mean he goes he's once you have kids all
these things are affecting their
day-to-day lives right you're worried
about what your kid's learning in school
you're worried about how they're seeing
the world the music and the video games
and the teacher everything that you're
old enough to not give a [ __ ] about and
just remove yourself from they're
learning every day and they're asking
you about saying yo tell me what the
[ __ ] this is that's so funny my friend
of ours uh said this he is a he's a he's
living in Canada you guys know what I'm
talking about and um
and he gave like two treats to one of
his uh kids to his daughter and like one
tree to his son and his son goes to his
dad and mom he goes uh hey
fair and equal
and he goes what'd you say he goes fair
and equal she got to I get to and he's
like we need to move back to America
life is not fair and equal yeah
sometimes someone else is gonna get two
treats you'll get one treat you gonna
have to learn how to deal with that [ __ ]
we used to get told this all the time
and I feel like they stopped saying it
to kids life's not fair you remember
that anytime you complain to your
parents I'm unfair life's not fair yeah
it was such an important lesson and it's
just gone do they still say I don't know
I don't remember any of my nephews
getting told my wife said I I heard one
mom say it I thought she was just having
like a bad day or something my mom used
to say [ __ ] in one hand wish another see
which one fills up faster
how do parents have time for such long
like sayings my mom never had a fat mom
my mom never had like little like
aphorisms or nothing you know I mean
they scream across the house Mom I can't
find this should go are you looking with
their eyes are you looking with your
mouth
I used to [ __ ] clown me all day
I wish the stigma of liberals like goes
away because people consider liberals
like ah hippies they don't care about
[ __ ] they're not physically conservative
and all that type of [ __ ] it's like you
can
care you can grow up get older care
about money and still be Progressive and
yeah you know whose fault that is though
right it's liberals no I understand but
I'm just saying it's like not all
Liberals are yeah I wish the same thing
would happen with [ __ ] conservatives
like not all these conservatives are
[ __ ] like these uh crazy Trump you
know Nazi [ __ ] like yeah I
think that generally speaking the the
Romney conservative and the the Clinton
Democrat that's like the last Democrat I
remember people who say like are about
this far away yeah on the Spectrum even
the Obama Democrats
the Obama democrat and the Romney
conservatives are this far yeah yeah
basically just how do you like better
Romney's health care plan is what
Obamacare is yes
these are the same people it makes sense
so yeah yeah sorry you know what's
interesting when you said about having
kids and everything flips every 30 years
these group of kids have a music that
the parents hate and the parents are
like get this [ __ ] out of here let's
burn all the CDs and the kids are like
how could you free speech and then 30
years later they're the parents burning
their kids CDs first it's rock and roll
then it's specific rock and roll like
Mick Jagger whatever the [ __ ] it was
back then then it's Eminem those same
parents I listened to Rolling Stones and
beetles are burning the m m CDs and now
the parents are burning whatever lgbtq
there's too much get critical race
Theory out and it's like or like this
this guy's offensive this artist yo you
were just laughing at the parents who
were burning your m m CDs those guys are
our age at 38 and they're oh my kids
can't be exposed to this it's so funny
when you have kids everything is because
we know the music is bad
like the music is responsible yeah you
know what I mean like like we know our
parents are right they were right
they were right we
right it's like I want Linda
Linda Felicia
okay let's do one more then we gotta get
out of here all right oh there was one
dude I looked like Spanish
what's up what's up yeah from Dallas
Texas what's up all right so my question
is
do you still look for validation within
the goats of Comedy uh like Dave
Chappelle or Louis CK or any of your
other goats that you looked up to
um do you still seek that validation I
know you've technically made it but is
there people that you still look up to
and if not in comedy what about goats in
other Industries like CEOs or music or
any other industries that you like I
[ __ ] with y'all let's go
absolutely
I don't think it's